[Music]
don't buy that 40 000 truck please don't
that seems very personal joshua
although i do remember i saved up one
summer to try and buy
a
car
and i i spent all my money
on a buick regal and the sound system
and then i had the chevy caprice with
the gold dayton's dude that was awesome
you're really cool you don't know
nothing about dayton's danny yeah no he
doesn't i mean you're the coolest you're
the coolest 18 year old
in 1999
yeah so avoid that forty thousand dollar
truck and there's something but there's
nothing wrong with a forty thousand
dollar truck if you can afford it yeah i
mean the the problem is yes when you are
when you're a slave to that forty
thousand dollar debt payment like that's
where maybe becker is coming from
but you know even dave ramsey will tell
you like hey look when you buy a brand
new car
it's it's not an investment
it is a it's a waste of money that said
if you have zero debt
and you can and you have your uh
emergency fund fully funded and you've
got the money saved up to buy a new car
then go ahead and do it no that's not
going to be an asset for you
but if you're going to do it here's how
to do it responsibly i think that's a
great point ryan because what you're
really saying here is
if you have to finance a car
you can't afford it yeah
if you don't have enough money in the
bank to buy that car
you can't afford it
yeah you could tick-tock that danny did
you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free